lawmakers in germany have voted in favor
of mandatory vaccines for health care
workers the law requires medical staff
to show proof of vaccination or recovery
by mid-march exceptions will be made on
health grounds dentists pharmacists and
vets will also be allowed to give jabs
germany is struggling to break the
fourth wave of the pandemic the new
health minister who is also an
epidemiologist hopes the measures will
stop the omicron variant from having an
overwhelming impact
we want to strengthen our infection
protection law to give all german states
the tools they need to get a grip on
infection levels
they can ban large public gatherings and
big sports events
they can close down bars clubs and
discos
they'll even be able to shut restaurants
if necessary
we're providing the means to break the
delta wave regionally and nationally and
doing all we can to prevent a powerful
omicron wave
let's get more on this from our
political correspondent jared reed uh
jared talk us through what the lawmakers
have decided today
well michael lawmakers have decided that
healthcare workers in hospitals and in
elderly care homes will have to get a
covert jab by march of next year they'll
have to prove that by march or they'll
have to prove too that they have been
recovered or that they have an exemption
from this and if they don't then they
won't be able to come to work what was
debated and passed today was an update
to the infection
law that also gives other kinds of
health care workers so pharmacists
dentists and even veterinarians the
ability to be able to administer covert
jobs some more
rights were given to states as well they
this will allow them to order the
closures of clubs discos uh and
restaurants so this is all done and
dusted this has passed both of the
houses of parliament here so we have
this on one side compulsory vaccinations
in for some uh
for healthcare workers on the other hand
we know that very soon the parliament is
going to be debating compulsory vaccines
for all this is something that uh the
new chancellor olaf schultz would like
to see simply because of the uh not
enough people are vaccinated fully
vaccinated here in germany still under
70 of the population
no doubt tough measures for tough times
give our international viewers a sense
of how critical the covet situation is
in germany right now jared
well it is critical it's been named by
the new government as its number one
priority and we know that infection
numbers are still far too high they have
sort of been leveling off over the last
week or so but it is still too high we
know that there are hundreds of people
who are dying of covert 19 still in
germany every day so the government set
up a crisis team headed by a two-star
general that will report to it
every day olaf schultz has also said
that he wants uh 30 million vaccines to
be administered by christmas time it
looks like he might get there it's
looking fairly promising on thursday we
know that around a million vaccines were
administered here in germany well
despite all this vaccine hesitancy is
persistent is it likely jared that even
workers in the medical sector will
resist compulsory vaccination
well this has been quite a worry of the
government it's a bit of a tricky
balancing act because over the last two
years have been a lot of healthcare
staff that have left the profession so
the government doesn't want more to
leave but it also doesn't want
people who work in the healthcare sector
to come into contact with covert 19 and
pass it on to sick and elderly people so
it is a real juggling act we know
generally in the population there is
strong support for compulsory vaccines
as always a deep thanks jared reed
let's talk about all this with
epidemiologist tobias kurt mr kurt in
view of the infection figures do you
think government should pass these
suggested measures
yes i think so there should be tools
where the government or governmental
structures can intervene and
put measures in place that the numbers
will go down that's a really important
thing and we started unfortunately too
late to break the delta wave earlier and
now we need to get these numbers down as
quickly as possible to be prepared for
the omicron wave
do you believe the suggested measures
will be effective enough to break this
fourth wave in germany
we know since the beginning that if we
reduce the contact among people and
reduce the ability that people can
mingle in in large events sport events
etc that will bring the numbers down so
that was the case in the first wave the
second wave the third wave and now on
the fourth wave we're seeing some
numbers already indicating that the
infection rate goes down but we need to
do better to really get these numbers
down more quickly
uh the new uh health minister is khal
lauterbach an epidemiologist who many
germans trust what would you like to see
from him in the coming weeks and months
i'm in not a position to really give him
recommendation he's an expert in the
field and he needs to evaluate now very
quickly the situation the vaccine the
the next possible steps that the
government can do and really communicate
clearly to the people and make clear
that everybody as good as possible
understands the urgency that we are in
right now
i want to ask you potentially a
sensitive question but one that needs to
be asked what should the previous
government have done in order to prevent
this fourth wave from occurring the way
it
occurs to be
happening right now
i think that we learned a lot during the
pandemic in the beginning it was very
difficult to judge what could be done
and then things
actually went into place i think the the
critical point was the
the in between two governments where
people did not make decisions and really
we allowed the delta wave to increase so
it was not a
question of a specific ministry or a
specific government it was that the
decision makers did not understand the
severity of the situation and that we
should have acted earlier now everything
is in place the booster campaign for the
boost vaccination is ongoing that's
really important we need to increase
also the test capacities and communicate
to the people more clearly that whenever
they have smaller symptoms they stay
home they need to get tested and make
sure that i'm not spreading the
infection specifically while we're
waiting in germany to the omicron
variant
thank you so much that's epidemiologist
tobias kurt
thank you for having me